and as we mentioned we are just minutes
away from Robert Muller's historic
testimony on Capitol Hill the former
special counsel arrived just moments ago
to answer questions about his 22 month
Russia investigation he will appear
twice today first before the House
Judiciary
and then the Intelligence Committee the
Intelligence Committee will likely focus
on volume one of the Moller report that
covers Russian election interference the
Judiciary Committee will likely focus on
volume to covering possible obstruction
of justice by President Trump we expect
the questioning to break along partisan
lines Democrats are likely to ask about
the details of the report and why mr.
Muller did not reach a conclusion on
obstruction charges Republicans are
expected to ask about the probe and how
it started and look at potential
conflicts of interest among the
investigators Paula Reed is at the White
House and joins us now so Paula have you
heard from the president or the sources
close to the president that he's worried
about the political fallout from this
testimony Vlada senior administration
official tells CBS News they don't
believe this is going to be a Matlock
moment they believe if you've read the
report you know what Muller is going to
say and in his last press availability
mother said just that he said any
testimony that he gives is going to be
his report that's part of why the
president's legal team today is
expressing confidence president's
personal attorney Rudy Giuliani tells
CBS News he believes Democrats cannot
rewrite the reports conclusion that no
case can be brought now President Trump
has been weighing in on Twitter he said
that he believes Democrats are wasting
their time he thinks that this hearing
will make it look to voters like he is
being harassed he also tweeted that he
believes it's quote very unfair that
former special counsel Muller will get
to have a deputy president for these
hearings he is of course referring to
longtime Muller aide Aaron Zev Lee who
will be sitting with the former special
counsel at both hearings this morning
the president tweeted saying that
Democrats quote illegally fabricated a
crime and blamed it on what he calls a
quote very innocent president he also
slammed Muller and suggested that he
should look into the origins of the
investigation important reminder the
Justice Department is investigating how
the Russia the Russia probes started and
if the
or any political motivations at the
outset now Paula president Trump at
first said he will not watch the
testimony then maybe a little bit of the
testimony so as of this morning what do
we know about whether White House TVs
will be tuned into the hearing well he
signaled that he might be among those
tuning in to watch at least some of the
hearing so far today his schedule is
pretty clear until about 4:00 p.m. so
we'll have the opportunity to tune in
and at that 4:00 p.m. event it would not
be surprising if he use that opportunity
to weigh in on the hearing but we should
also watch Twitter
all right Paula read for us at the White
House Paula thank you